That's the ocean. I didn't
even know it was there.
Where'd you come from, ocean?
Where you been all my life, girl please.
I've been doing challenges
for my body, heart, mind,
and soul, and we're at
the fourth episode, y'all.
I'm gonna be going on the
ultimate self-care experience.
That means I'm gonna be going someplace
where I've never been before,
I'm gonna be eating alone,
I'm gonna be staying by
myself, and I'm just gonna be
using this time to reflect on
everything that I've learned
in the first three episodes
with my body, heart, and mind.
I'm hoping that by the end of this weekend
I am feeling calm, collected,
less anxious, less of a mess,
and ready to arrive at my 30th birthday.
Good morning.
Okay, so I just finished brunch by myself,
and I think I was really nervous at first,
but then like I don't know,
time by yourself is so valuable.
And I think we forget that.
I think as women we've been socialized
to be super accommodating.
When there was no one
to like ask how they were feeling
and if everything was okay, except myself,
I felt this deep part of me just relax.
The day so far has been pretty good.
I've just been doing
everything that I want to do,
for once, which is really nice.
This fortune teller set up shop
in this cute house on the pier.
She's like, as your
approaching this new chapter
in your life, you need to
learn how to receive more.
Because that's the good part of life.
You know you're working really
hard, and you're making sure
that you're there for your friends.
I don't like it when people give me gifts
or pay me compliments.
You're not gonna be able
to know your self-worth
until you learn how to do this.
I kinda needed to hear that today.
There's this thought: "Should I go out?
Should I go to a bar?" My soul said, "No."
I just really want to chill.
I'm doing a face mask.
This is Olay's Fresh Reset.
When I'm on vacation, either
with my family or my boyfriend,
I feel like I have to kind
of like utilize every second,
go out every night, and do all the events.
I have to be honest with
you: Like if I truly ask
what I want right now, it's just rest.
At the end of all these challenges,
and as I transition to
my 30th year of life,
I can honestly say that
I feel better turning 30
than I did when I was 21.
I highly recommend setting
aside some time where you can
take a look at your body,
mind, heart, and soul.
Set some intentions, set
some challenges for yourself,
just so you can kind of go
into your next year of life
or go into this next milestone
feeling prepared and feeling ready.
You know, everything happens for a reason,
and I'm here for a reason.
I think I'm in the right spot right now.